So I did a tweet. This was crazy to me. This is how sensitive the world is.
This was crazy to me. I wrote, I did a,
a thing I put on my Instagram TV and it was a, um,
a, uh, a clip of me kind of just messing with the audience.
You could look at up my, Oh, you can look at it on YouTube too.
And I was talking to these people in the crowd and they were, they were,
they turned out, they were down. These thing called my, not my only fans. God.
Why do I always want to call it that it's called only fans.
For those of you that don't know what only fans is,
you can go on and subscribe to checks and they show you their fried
butterfly and Bobi lobbies.
And you can do it for like nine 99 a month or whatever the, by the way,
that always tripped me, who the is getting tricked by the nine 99.
It's $10, dude. If I ever have a company, I don't want it to be nine 99.
I want it to be 10 bucks. As a matter of fact, that.
I'm gonna make it 10 Oh one. When I was a kid, I would always be like,
why does it say nine 99? It's just 10 bucks.
Why don't they just say 10 bucks on my mom will be like, well,
that's because it's, you know, it makes it seem like it's less money. I'm like,
it's 1 cent less money, dude. What kind of idiot is like,
well, that's cheaper than $10. Are you idiots,
dude, even as a children's.
I knew that even as a children's,
I knew that I was for one of my first words was like,
why did it made it a 1999?
I went to throw my $200 and my mom was like, well,
because people think it's less money, definitely 1 cent lower
Dumb dude. If you're buying some, that's nine 99,
because you think that it's less than $10 as 1 cent.
So anyway,
you can subscribe on only fans for nine 99 or
1599 or two 99 or whatever the it is. If the girl has it,
doesn't have that good of a body. And maybe it's the less money. I don't know.
Or duck lips are bad. It's less money. Or maybe it's more money if you're like
I dunno. I feel like Persian guys love all that. Persian guys. Not only fans,
but Persian guys love the, Oh. She put all that much makeup on. That's amazing,
bro. She's out to go. She's out to go out tonight, bro. Oh man.
She put even more collagen in her lip dog. That's it, man.
I want my girl looking like a Simpson dog. That's crazy bro. She did her hair.
Really nice dog. Look at that man.
Look how much deputy use dog
A dog. That's awesome. Look at that outfit, bro.
She's got three outfits on at the same time dog.
She's got an outfit on and then on top of that, she's got an outfit on.
And then on top of that dog, she's got another outfit on dog and then she,
she didn't even use a makeup dog. She used to paint on her face.
She used house paint dog on her face. contouring dog.
She used the white and black paint
and then she told her doctor to put straight up cement in her lips, dog.
She's so hot.
She can't even keep her head up because of the house paint and cement in her
mouth, the dog,
she basically drags her face on the ground dark and she pushes it
forward and she's sweating so hard. Cause she's got three office on doc.
Um, what the was I even talking about? Oh yeah. Only fans. Um,
only fans.
So this girl was talking about how she does only fans and I knew what it was
kinda, but I didn't really know. And,
and I was like, and she was like, I'm on only fans. And I was like, Oh,
you're on that. So I was kinda like not roasting her,
but kind of just having fun with it and the audience and making fun of it.
It's on YouTube. You can look at it,
they'll add a link or something on the bottom. And uh,
at the don't want fire and I haven't get rid of, but um,
and so I was like, so I tweeted something and I wrote God,
this is so everyone's so sensitive. This is crazy. I wrote I'm on only fans.
Cause it was on my mind. I wrote I'm on only fans.
Can't wait to show you my for 40 bucks thinking how funny would it
be if me a 39 year old male
comedian not gay straight,
like not trying to pimp other like dudes
so they could see my.
Hey K a chess cause Don habitats. Um,
can't wait to show my for 40 bucks would it would be funny if you don't think a
49 year old or a 49, a 39. Woopsy my secrets out.
If you don't think a 39 year old
showing his guy on only fans for 40 bucks is
funny. Then I can help you. I can help you.
Especially if it already has a successful career doing something else can't help
you can't help you.
You don't think that visual is funny or even the idea? No,
not even the visual to me. The visual is not even,
what's funny for a 39 year old guy who's successful in another arena
to be like gotta be on only fans and show my for $40.
You don't think that's funny. What enough want nothing to do with?
You could grab a towel in there. Want nothing to do there.
Now I'm out here spilling caveman coffee on that. That's how it's me off. Right?
Um, so.
Thanks bro.
So I, I, uh,
I tweeted that and at first it was like, you know,
it was getting a lot of traction. I was like, that's funny.
I guess people think it's funny.
And then people were like really
mad about it. Like actually
like,
and it wasn't the girls really that do only fans.
Like if some of the girls were like, ha ha let's.
But like these guys,
I don't know. We're like great stuff here. Funny stuff, man.
Hilarious teeth kissed up laughing, keep it up, bro.
Somebody else like obviously sarcasm. Somebody else wrote hysterical, man.
Like egging me on. And then some other guy was like,
Oh, you're going to some other people like, shame me. Oh, you're going to,
you know, we're out here getting killed. All right, dude.
First of all, to get the facts, to, to think about the fact, to think that, um,
first of all, to think that I'm somehow
Making fun of only fans in that tweet,
you just don't get the joke. First of all, second of all,
if I am making fun of only fans who gives a,
you gotta be, you gotta be, you make fun of everything.
Comedians make fun of everything. So shut the F relax.
You can be offended if you want, but you can't tell me not to say some. Okay.
Cause I'm gunna now.
But people were like, people are, are out here getting killed, you know,
because of this. Yeah. Okay, cool, man. I'm not making fun of that.
And also if I was okay, it's Twitter,
but like to be,
It just is like
the Kack dudes that were like trying to come to the rescue or the worst, like,
dude,
you're not getting laid because you're the friend guy,
you know,
you're not coming to the defense of the people that could come to their own
defense. By the way
you taking that away from women is the prob is,
is one of the problems like women can
can say no, they can,
they can do this when guys step in and are like,
Hey, it's not right. Your being sexist dude.
Oh.
I'll handle this day. Ma I'll don't worry.
Sweet tart. I'll handle this dude. Sit the down.
Girls can say, you. How about that, dude,
if they're equal, then they can say, you. How about that? Do
you cook mother also it's Twitter.
If you don't think something's funny on Twitter.
That's cause it's Twitter dude.
All the I say on Twitter is not funny. It sucks. It's cause it's free.
You want to see something funny? Come see the act of worked out
complaining about free content is great, dude. It's like,
aye. I,
I it's so annoying when people take the wrong way. I hate that.
I making fun of me showing my and people are like, you know what so much.
Here's the other thing about it.
If you think I'm making fun of only fans and you're mad because I
say, Hey, I joined only fans. I can't wait to show my for $40.
If you take that,
that's literally what only fans is.
It's literally what it is.
You're paying to see girls show the bits and pieces.
So I'm saying that, so take that out of it.
Like the humor, take the humor, whatever you think out of it.
It's literally what is that?
Therefore,
how are you mad at me for saying quite literally what it is?
You're mad all over the place for zero reason.
And also it doesn't matter.
I'm by the way,
get your money. No, of course. Get your money,
get your money, get your money, dude. I think it's awesome.
So awesome.
If you've got and you want to charge dudes to see them
get that
Skrilla and I barely say skrela okay.
[Inaudible].
I barely say Scrilla but if you've got and you've got a
fried butterfly and you want to say, Hey, dude,
want to see it for $11? And the dude goes, yup.
Then Ray, get in.
[Inaudible].
Right. Get it. And dude, get $11 from this guy.
Get $11 from that guy. Get $11 from another guy,
get $11 from the cook that thinks he's defended women,
but he's not because women can defend themselves. And then guess what?
You've got $44 just for having tests.
Dude. I love only, and I love the girls on them.
And if you're trying to act like I don't then go yourself.
Kuk.
[Inaudible].
That's a delayed Jeremy Renner sting.
I don't.
Mark. You're not going to put me in a hole that I'm not in. Dude,
show that and make $11.
[Inaudible].
Show that to a guy, collect $11.
Show that to another guy, collect $11.
Show that to another guy who's married and sad,
collect $11 and show that to another guy
who thinks he's defended women when women can defend themselves and don't take
their autonomy away from it and make $11. And then guess what?
You have $44.
[Inaudible].
That's lunch for two days.
I mean, dude, you're not going to put me in a hole, dude.
I'm climbing the out that hole.
And that's why we listen to this podcast.
And that's why we listen to this podcast, dude,
because we break down all of the real issues. NPR,
all the podcasts where people talk about worldly events, dude,
suck them all. Dude, we talk about the real like on the fence and.
Whatever [inaudible].
I loved Jeremy Renner for making that song.
He's a talented actor and I'm his biggest fan dude.
Would drink my babies.